Transcriber: Ceyda B. Dağ
Gözden geçirme: Eren Gokce
Bir gün önce metropol bir şehirde
kombinin fazla
ısıtmasından şikâyet ederken,
bir gün sonra bir dağ köyünde
sobanın yanında titrerken
buldunuz mu kendinizi hiç?
Ben buldum.
Hem de sobanın tavanda
bıraktığı gölgeleri izlerken
üzerinde kaynayan çayın,
sadece o an üşüyen ellerimi değil
bir ömür bütün bedenimi
ısıtacağını bilmeden.
Herkes hayatında inişler çıkışlar yaşar.
Herkes hayatta yapmam,
yapamam dediği şeyin
tam ortasında bulur kendini bazen.
Bazen bütün ümitler
tükenmişken bir umut beliriverir,
ya umuda tutunur dipten yukarıya çıkarız
ya da o hengamenin
rüzgârında savrulur gideriz.
Teknik anlamda da öyle değil midir;
alçak basınçla yüksek basınç
arasında yer değiştiren
hava akımı miktarıdır ya rüzgâr,
işte biraz da yaşamın kıyısında,
alçak basınç dolaylarında
yaşamına devam ederken
hayattan aldığı dersle
yaşamın farkına varan
bir insanın, bir öğretmenin, bir köy
öğretmeninin hikâyesi bu.
Bırakın rüzgârda savrulmayı,
rüzgâr olmaya niyetlenen
cinsten bir hikâye.
Her şey, 2010 yılının
soğuk bir Cumartesi günü,
ailemden yüzlerce kilometre
uzaklıkta, 1800 rakımda,
hatta şu an bulunduğumuz salona
1.020 kilometre uzaklıktaki bir dağ köyüne
öğretmen olarak atanmamla başladı her şey.
Konuşmaları, dili, adetleri,
gelenek ve görenekleri alışmış
olduğum tarzın dışında olan,
arama motorlarında aradığınızda
donmuş tilki görselleri dışında
pek bir görselin olmadığı o diyara
yaklaşık 12 saat süren bir
yolculuğun ardından ulaşmıştık.
Köye gelir gelmez otobüsten indim,
etrafa baktım;
evet, internette aradığım
yerin ta kendisiydi
ama öncesinde göreve başlama
işlemlerini halletmek amacıyla
il merkezine, il Milli Eğitim
Müdürlüğü'ne gitmem gerekiyordu.
Hemen oradan bir taksi çevirdim.
Taksiciye "Beni köyden il
merkezine götürür müsün?" dedim.
Taksici böyle afallamış bir şekilde,
"Hocam zaten il merkezindesin." dedi.
Tabii o an bir hayal
kırıklığına kapılıyorsunuz,
sizin köy sandığınız yer,
il merkezi çıkıyor.
Sonra tabii o şaşkınlığı üzerimden
atamadan il merkezine gittik,
orada evrak işlerini tamamladık,
sonra ilçeye geldik.
İlçede bir banka, İlçe Milli Eğitim
Müdürlüğü, bir market, sonra ilçe bitti.
İlçe de o kadar.
Sonra tabii hayal kırıklığı
artarak devam ediyordu.
Orada da işlemleri hallettikten sonra
yaklaşık bir 70 kilometre daha yol yapıp
o dağ köyüne ulaşmıştık.
Yanımda üç valizle
bana bir ev gösterdiler;
toplamda 30 metrekare büyüklüğünde,
bir odası var,
1+1 diyorlar ya "sadece 1".
O kadar odası var.
Kapıdan içeriye girdim
valizlerle birlikte,
köşede bir kanepe var.
Kanepe, valizler, ben, kapı;
hatta ben çıkmadan kapı kapanmıyor
o kadar küçük bir odası var.
Neyse kapıyı kapatır kapatmaz
aklıma gelen ilk düşünce şu oldu:
Emre ne yap ne et, burayı terk et.
Çünkü o an yaşadığım
hayal kırıklıkları üst üste gelmişti.
Hemen araştırmaya koyuldum.
Ne yapmalıyım, dedim,
öğretmen nasıl tayin olur, nasıl gider.
Hemen, dedim, cep telefonunu
çıkarayım, internete yazayım.
Tam yazacağım, baktım ki internet
çekmiyor; aslında hat yok.
Sonra neyse ki yanımda
yedek bir hat getirmiştim,
yedek hattı taktım,
ondan sonra araştırmaya koyuldum,
işte öğretmen nasıl
bulunduğu yerden gider vesaire diye.
Sonra gelen sonuçlardan
iki tanesi beni oradan kurtarıyor;
ya evleneceksiniz, eş durumundan
eşinizin bulunduğu ile tayin olacaksınız
ya da yüksek lisans yapıp yüksek lisans
yaptığınız üniversiteye tayin oluyorsunuz.
İki yol var, dedim ki ben hem iyi
bir yuva kurayım, hayırlı bir yuva kurayım
hem de buradan kaçayım diye,
hemen bu işlerle ilgilenen kişi olarak
annemi telefonla aradım.
"Anne," dedim, "Ben evleneceğim.
Bana birisini bulur musun?"
Sağ olsun, o hâlâ birini bulmaya
çalışıyor, devam ediyor.
O konudaki çalışmalarımız,
başarısızlıkla sonuçlandıktan sonra,
"Ben akademik kariyer yapayım,
entelektüel bir kişilik kazanırım
hem de tayin olurum." diye düşündüm.
Hemen araştırmalara başladım.
Ondan sonra, çok yakın bir zamanda
bir bölümden alım var.
Arkeoloji Bölümü'nden 10 kişi alınacak.
Her şey tamam. Bölüm arkeoloji,
benim branşım fen bilimleri.
Çok az başvuru olduğu için,
her bölümden başvuruyu kabul ediyorlardı.
Hemen başvuru yaptım.
Sonuçların açıklanmasını bekliyoruz.
Güzel olan tarafı şöyle;
10 kişi alınacak, 6 kişi başvurmuş.
Garanti gidiyorum oradan,
artık elveda diyorum o dağ köyüne.
Ondan sonra, erken bir açıklama geldi
üniversitenin sitesinden.
Ben bir hayretle açtım baktım,
acaba sonuçlar mı açıklandı, diye.
Baktım ki aynen şu açıklama yazıyor:
"Arkeoloji Bölümünden açıklama:
Birimimizdeki profesörlerden bir tanesi
başka bir üniversiteye tayin
olduğundan dolayı Arkeoloji Bölümünden
yüksek lisans alımlarının
durdurulmasına karar verilmiştir."
Orada da darbeyi yemiştik.
Ne yaparsam yapayım, oradan kaçış
planlarının hepsi suya düşüyordu.
Tabii ki, bu sırada bir yandan da
görevime devam ediyorum.
Bir yandan okuluma gidiyorum.
Çok güzel insanlar var,
çok güzel öğrenciler var.
Ama benim içimdeki aileme kavuşma isteği,
oradan gitme isteği hiç bitmiyor.
Oradan kurtulmaya çalışıyorum,
gitmek istiyorum.
Ta ki geldiğim günden beri beni takip eden
bir çift masum göz ile karşılaşana kadar.
O masum gözlerin sahibi ilk başlarda ürkek
bakışlarla beni uzaktan takip ediyor.
Sonradan, evden okula giderken
okuldan eve gelirken de
beni takip ettiğini fark ettim.
Benim de canım sıkılıyordu.
Bir arkadaşa ihtiyacım vardı.
Dedim gideyim, bu öğrenciyle tanışayım.
Dedim "Gel bakalım oğlum.
İşte benim adım Emre."
Dedi "Benim adım da Ahmet, hocam."
"Memnun oldum Ahmet."
Hemen Ahmet anlatmaya koyuldu.
Zamanında babasıyla dağlardan topladığı
yaban armutlarından bahsediyor,
mantar toplamaya çıktıklarını söylüyor,
"Ankara'da da sizin böyle dağlarınız
var mı?
Orada insanlar nasıl konuşuyor?"
diye bana sorular soruyor...
Ben anlatıyorum, o dinliyor;
o anlatıyor, ben dinliyorum derken
günler haftaları, haftalar ayları
kovaladı.
İlk öğretmenler günü geldi çattı.
Tabii ki, hani her ne kadar
oradan kurtulmaya çalışsanız da
öğretmenler günü ve ilk olması, sizde
farklı bir duygu bütünlüğü oluşturuyor.
Sabahleyin, farklı bir sevinçle
okula gittim.
Öğrencilerim dağlardan topladıkları
çiçekleri getirmişler,
kimisi mektup yazmış, kimisi şiir...
Farklı farklı hediyeler getirenler var.
Tabii insan en yakın dostundan, Ahmet'ten,
kankasından da bir şeyler bekliyor.
Baktım, Ahmet şimdi gelir,
sürpriz yapacak herhâlde, derken
Ahmet o gün derse gelmedi.
Bazen yaşlı annesine yardım etmek amacıyla
geç geldiği vakitler oluyordu.
Dedim, şimdi gelir, geldi derken
öğle arası oldu, Ahmet hâlâ yoktu.
Allah Allah, dedim.
Buruk bir sevinçle de böyle
Ahmet'i arıyorum.
Okul bahçesini, sınıfı...
Ahmet o gün yoktu.
Neyse, ders bitti. Okuldan çıktım.
İçimdeki o Ahmet'in her an çıkabileceği
düşüncesi ile baka baka köy yoluna doğru,
evime gittim.
Evin de tahta bir kapısı var.
Bazen şiddetli rüzgâr estiğinde
kendiliğinden açılan bir kapı.
Oradan girdim.
Hemen yan tarafı da mutfak.
Yemek yapmaya koyuldum.
Yemeği yapıyorum.
Sonra kapı hafif bir titreşti böyle.
Dedim herhâlde
yine rüzgâr yapıyor bunu.
Fazla kulak kesilmedim derken baktım ki
kapı ritmli bir şekilde çalınıyor.
Herhalde kapıda birisi var, diye gittim,
kapıyı açtım, baktım, kapıda kimse yok.
Allah Allah, dedim.
Tam kafamı çevirdim ki
güneşin kızıllığına doğru
bir çift ayağın kaybolduğunu gözlemledim.
Dedim, herhâlde çocuklar
benimle oyun oynuyor.
Çünkü bazen bunu yapıyorlardı.
Sonra kapıdan tam geri çekilip
böyle baktığımda kapının eşiğinde
gazete kağıdının içine buruşturulmuş
bir paket var.
Allah Allah, bu ne, diye
bir merakla eğildim, aldım.
Ağır da bir paket.
Gazete kağıdını açtım.
Kağıdın içerisinde bir taş var.
Taşın üzerinde de güzel taş yazıyor.
[Güzel Taş]
Allah Allah, bu ne, diye düşünürken
hani gazete kağıdının üst kısmında
manşetin olduğu yerde bir boşluk olur ya?
Oraya eğri büğrü harflerle
yazılmış bir not:
"Öğretmenim! Ben Ahmet.
Kusura bakmayın, öğretmenler gününüzü
kutlamaya okula gelemedim.
Arkadaşlarım benimle dalga geçer diye.
Bu taş benim en değerli eşyam.
Lütfen kabul edin.
Öğretmenler gününüz kutlu olsun.
Kankanız Ahmet." yazıyor altında.
Düşünebiliyor musunuz?
En değerli eşyası bir taş.
Ve daha sonraları öğrendiğimde,
rahmetli babasıyla tarlada çalışırken
babasının topraktan çıkarıp
oğluna hediye ettiği bu taşı,
oradan kaçmak için
elinden geleni ardına koymayan
kendini öğretmen sanan birisine
hediye ediyordu.
Ahmet aslında bir hediyeden ziyade
bana hayat dersi veriyordu.
Dedim ya herkes hayatında
inişler çıkışlar yaşar,
o mesajı alacağı günü bekler diye.
İşte o gün o taşı avucumun içine aldığımda
bırakın mesaj almayı tüm bedenimi
saran bir sıcaklığa maruz kalmıştım.
Taşlar...
Hani dışarıdan baktığınızda
çok soğuk çok sert objelerdir değil mi?
Ahmet'in verdiği taş...
Bakın burada.
Hiç bir taşı kırıp içine baktınız mı?
İçinde milyonlarca mineralin
parladığını görürsünüz.
Milyonlarca rengârenk mineral...
Ya ben bu taşın içindeki
o milyonlarca mineralin parlamasına
ya da Ahmet'in o gönlündeki rengârenk
milyonlarca parıltıya inananlardanım.
İşte bu taş, beni sizin karşınıza çıkaran
olaylar silsilesini başlatan şey.
Gelin hep birlikte, o günden sonra
neler olmuş, bir seyre çıkalım.
Platon, devleti,
aynı bir insan organizmasına benzetiyor.
İnsan organizmasındaki farklı yapıları da
insanların yerine getirdiği
yapılar olarak adlandırıyor.
Öyle ki "İnsanı geliştirirseniz
otomatikman devlet gelişir." diyor.
O zaman biz de öyle yapmalıydık.
İnsanı geliştirmeliydik, değil mi?
Daha sonra çalışmalara koyulduğumuzda
"Bir devletin
gelişmişlik düzeyine bakmak istiyorsanız
orada kadınların yaşam standardına bakın."
diyor Stuart Mill.
Çok önemli.
O hâlde ilk önce
kadınlardan başlamamamız lazımdı.
İlk öğretmenlerimizden.
Çünkü kadınları geliştiremezsek
biz okullarda ne yaparsak yapalım
öğretemezdik.
Öyle de yaptık.
Yaptığımız araştırmalar
ve hazırladığımız projeler sonucunda
köyümüzde ve ilçemizde bulunan
bütün kadınlara
meslek edindirme kursları düzenledik.
Bir yandan meslek ediniyorlar
bir yandan aile, ilçe hatta il ekonomisine
katkıda bulunmaya başladılar.
Sinemaya gidiyorlar, tiyatroya gidiyorlar,
müze gezileri...
Farklı kültürel faaliyetlerle
sosyalleşiyorlar.
O kadar güzel ki!
Belki de bizim onlara sağladığımız şey
maddiyattan öte
onların geleceğe umutla bakmalarıydı.
Gerçekten bizler için
en önemli projelerden bir tanesi olmuştu.
Daha sonra, okul yaşamına da
el atmamız gerekiyordu.
Sanırım nöbetçi olduğum günlerden bir gün
zil çalar çalmaz öğrencileri
okuldan eve doğru
koşar adım giderken gördüm.
Bir gariplik söz konusuydu.
Onları hayata hazırlayacak olan ilimin,
bilimin, teknolojinin merkezi olması
gereken okullar,
koşar adım kaçılan yerler olmuştu.
Aslında öğrenciler de haksız sayılmazdı.
Okullara şöyle dönüp baktığınızda
o soğuk betonsu görünümü
gerçekten insanda
olumsuz bir algı yaratıyordu.
Sonra kolları sıvadık.
Tüm okulumuzu öyle bir elden geçirdik ki
sınıflarımız tavanında güneş sisteminden
bir galaksinin olduğu renk tayfından,
kalorifer petekleri insan DNA'sı şeklinde
öğretmen dolabı insan böbreği şeklinde,
öğretmen masası ağaç şeklinde...
Bir sürü şey.
Bırakın öğrencilerin
zil çalınca eve gitmesini
artık teneffüslerde bile
dışarıya çıkmaz olmuşlardı.
Yeter miydi yetmezdi.
Öğrencilerimizi bilimle ve teknolojiyle
buluşturmak istedik.
Ama gelin görün ki en yakın bilim merkezi
yaklaşık 800 kilometre uzaktaydı.
Biz öğrencilerimiz oraya götüremezdik ama
oradaki faaliyetlerin hepsini
onların ayağına getirebilirdik.
Bu felsefeyle yola çıktık ve bana
tekerleri patlamış, camları kırık,
10 yıldır hiç çalışmayan
bir otobüs gösterdiler.
Yine oraya bir sihirli değneğin
değmesi gerekiyordu.
Sonra kablolar tak, kablolara akü ver,
yağlar, kayışlar derken
bir hafta sonunda
hurda otobüsü çalışır hâle getirdik.
İçine gerekli bilimsel düzenekleri
yerleştirdikten sonra
şu an günümüze kadar
40.000 tane köy öğrencisini
bilimsel faaliyetlerle tanıştırdık.
Neler yapıyorlar biliyor musunuz?
Mars'ta ağırlıklarını ölçüp
dinozorlara dokunabiliyorlar.
Meteoroloji istasyonunda hava tahmini
yapıp ay yüzeyinde yürüyüş yapabiliyorlar.
Öğrencilerimizi gerçekten bu şekilde
bilimsel faaliyetlerle buluşturmak
harika bir projeydi.
Hâlen de buluşturmaya devam ediyoruz.
Ama siz ne kadar bilim ve teknolojide
ilerleseniz de
bazen doğa olayları karşısında
çaresiz kaldığınız vakitler de oluyor.
Yine o günlerden bir gün
derse iki öğrencim çok geç gelmişti.
Yaklaşık 2 saat sonra.
Merak ettim.
Ağlayarak sınıfın içerisine girdiler.
Mosmor kesilmişler.
Ellerini avuçlarımın içine aldım,
böyle ısıtarak "Hayırdır,
neden geç kaldınız?" diye sordum onlara.
"Öğretmenim, biliyorsunuz, biz taşımalı
geliyoruz ve köyümüz çok uzakta.
Servis bazen kara takılıyor, 10 dakika geç
kalıyor, bazen yarım saat, bazen bir saat.
Biz de ha geldi ha gelecek derken
yerimizden ayrılamıyoruz
ve çok üşüyoruz öğretmenim." dediler.
Bizim bir öğrencimizin parmağının ucunun
dahi üşümesine tahammülümüz olamazdı.
Öyle de oldu ve projelerimizi yazdıktan
yaklaşık 6-7 ay sonra
32 tane taşımalı köyümüze,
güneş sistemiyle beslenen,
içinde ısıtmalı bir klimanın olduğu,
çalışma masasının olduğu,
kütüphanenin olduğu
akıllı duraklar projemizi inşa etmiştik.
Artık öğrencilerimiz üşümeden
keyifle servislerini bekliyorlardı.
Dedim ya "Onların tırnağının ucunun
dahi üşümesine tahammülümüz olamaz."
çünkü onlar nice kitapların sayfalarını
açacaklar ve nice kitapların sayfalarını
biz açalım diye onlar kitap yazacaklar.
Çünkü o nesil bu nesildi.
Onlara inanmamız gerekiyordu.
Ve...
bizim okumaya, okumak için
doğru düzgün alanlara ihtiyacımız vardı.
Çünkü gelişmiş ülkelere baktığınızda
%28'lik bir kitap okuma oranı varken
bizim ülkemizde yalnızca 1000'de 1'di.
Bu bizim için bir problemdi ama sadece
bu konunun üzerine gitmemiz de yeterliydi.
Bunu köy muhtarına açtık.
Bize damı akıtan, 40 yıl önce yapılmış
eski bir köy odasından bahsetti.
"Oraya çocukların gözüyle bakmak yeterdi."
diyorum ya
kestik, biçtik, boyadık, kaynattık derken
-30'larda iki ay çalışıp
"rahat kafe" isimli projemizi
hayata geçirdik.
[OKU]
Artık bizim köyümüzde kitap okuma oranı
bırakın 1000'de 1'i
çağdaş ülkelerin de ötesinde.
Evet, kitap okuyacağız, okumalıyız.
Bunları yaparken bir yandan da
toprak ne demek, üretmek ne demek,
üretim ne demek, hak etmek ne demek...
Bunları da öğrencilerimize
aşılamamız gerekiyordu.
Bu felsefeyle yola çıktık
ve dedik ki "Biz deftere yazarak değil,
toprağı kazarak öğreniyoruz."
ve uygulama bahçesi projesini
hayata geçirdik.
Ekiminden dikimine, sulamasından bakımına
her adımını öğrencilerimizin planladığı
bu projede çeşit çeşit ürünler elde ettik.
Ve bu elde ettiğimiz ürünlerin hepsini
yine "organik market" ismini verdiğimiz
atölyemizde işledik.
Reçeller, turşular, konserveler,
farklı farklı organik ürünler...
Düşünebiliyor musunuz?
Ve bunların hepsini satıp
hatırı sayılır bir gelir elde ettik.
Öğrencilere "Çocuklar, bu sizin paranız,
bu para sizin hakkınız. Ne yapalım bunu?"
diye sorduğumda
"Öğretmenim, bizim ihtiyacımız yok.
Yardımımıza muhtaç kardeşlerimize,
arkadaşlarımıza göndermek istiyoruz."
dediler ve son kuruşuna kadar
bunu yardıma muhtaç
kardeşleriyle paylaştılar.
Bu projeleri yaptıktan sonra bir gün
köyde yorulmuş ve oturuyordum çocuklarla.
Çocuklardan biri "Öğretmenim!" dedi,
"Neden bizim köydeki evler, binalar
hepsi eski ve gri renkte?" dedi.
Yani oraya da bir sihirli değneğin
değmesi gerekiyordu.
Sonra bir sosyal sorumluluk projesi
başlattık ve köyümüzdeki tüm evleri
öğrencilerimizle, velilerimizle birlikte
rengârenk yapmaya başladık.
Artık o taştan etrafa yayılan parıltılar
sadece bizim yüreklerimizi değil,
binaları da aydınlatmaya,
binaları da renklendirmeye başlamıştı.
O, Ahmet'in vermiş olduğu taş,
o taşın aydınlığı nereleri aydınlattı
hep birlikte gördük.
O taşı, ben, doğduğum şehirden
800 kilometre uzaklıkta,
1800 rakımda bir dağ köyünde buldum.
Peki, sizleri değiştirecek
olan taş nerede?